and really what this gets at is
something I find fascinating personally
which is just we really don't understand
the human body that well right we
understand a lot but it is such a
complex machine that we're still
learning things every single day and so
we're kind of doing the best we can with
the information we have right and that's
exactly why we bid it's crunching and
serenity our kind of patient facing Brad
I think there's a big misconception
about science and medicine and multiple
misconceptions but one of the biggest
one is that we know a lot like first of
all that's always a dumb assumption you
don't even know it like you'd know if
you don't know a lot about anything
physics or chemistry this or like all
these straightening the surface of
you're lucky but in biology it's
especially extreme I think when you were
in bed feel like every single time you
go below the surface and say oh this you
know causes cancer or something and then
you dig deeper into the protein and the
protein change the number of proteins we
actually understand what they do in
cancer is probably maximum a handful
probably more one or three like a
reservoir you know p53 or something I
mean even there it's very unclear all
the details are extremely odd yeah and
then you dig one layer deeper and you
have only questions and no answers and
you know every good scientist will tell
you well we simply don't know like you
have to run a bunch of experiments once
you run the experiments you probably
still don't know and you only have some
statistical or probabilistic inside and
I think that's very important in
medicine it's very different from for
example building Rockets right in
anything that's kind of artificially
created by humans we have a much better
understanding of if you build a computer
or a rocket you have a pretty
comprehensive understanding because you
build it everything that's naturally
occurring you have just no clue like
when you look at the body be if you're
lucky you know like 0.01 percent of
what's actually going and it's very
clear you know the deeper you take
they're just vast areas of unknowns yeah
and so would it be fair to say that
a lot of the work you guys are doing
obviously it's one trying to solve some
of this but but to just and the broader
science and health industry is that
we're really focused on just trying to
understand what's going on right right
the the solutions only come after we
understand and so that is really kind of
the the base layer and a lot of this
biotechnology and things that are being
seen as breakthroughs really it's just
identifying something that's been going
on in humans for you know thousands of
years we're just now starting to
understand given the technologies that
we have absolutely and I think there's a
huge paradigm shift going on in medicine
right now very slowly going on so that's
why being create a company to accelerate
it but the paradigm shift is the
medicine of the past and the current
medicine the way of doing medicine is is
very static right you go to med school
you learn a bunch of things and you
think you know something which is a big
mistake and I think the new paradigm in
medicine that newest serenity and
quantity and stand for is that it's a
much more dynamic system that is an
equation of basically three things data
you need a lot of data you need
intelligence you need to make sense of
the data and then action was systems
right you need to then take some 12
action and have some kind of
infrastructure to do treatments or more
Diagnostics
that's not how medicine works right now
medicine right now static knowledge see
like if that then do that whereas you
know I'll give you one example if you do
a conventional blood tests PSA for
example for prostate specific antigen
you get one number and says oh seven and
there's there it's above the threshold I
might have a problem maybe not when we
run a test on you especially the the
somatic mutation test for cancer
detection which we didn't get into yet
that's a different thing you're not
looking at your healthy genome we get
six billion data points so we get six
billion individual nucleotide reads out
of that example and then we have a very
complicated cloud-based you know
software AI system that makes sense of
that data and we are building base
Lia's on top of them to take in all
additional information around and that
system isn't perfect but it gives you an
idea you know what we are dealing with
you that system changes every week like
on on a deeper level because it learns
from patients and studies it gives us
literally 6 billion times more data
points than a normal sample and it's
operated on a different medical paradigm
and the medical care done is more data
is always better and more intelligence
and maybe us someone who's in taken
business you think like why is that like
a thing like isn't that obvious I of
course more than one but in medicine you
know the majority of physicians would
say no that's not true what data's
always it often bad because more data
means I may have to make decisions that
I don't want to make because if that
test comes back positive I have to do
some things according to standard oft
here therefore I would prefer not to do
the test and for non medical
professionals it sounds absurd
especially for taking time to like how
this makes any sense but it's about
standard procedures it's about
liabilities if I don't see it I can't do
anything wrong and that sounds
ridiculous maybe to you and many
listeners but it's literally what most
doctors would tell you like no it's a
young patient don't do their tests
because if it comes to a positive I have
to do all these things and that would be
wrong to do because it's the end page
and then you would I but if you know
it's wrong to do why do you do it like
well because it's standard procedure and
I don't want to get into trouble you
know that's so let's just not measure
anything
it's absolutely wild how the healthcare
system works it's it is wild and it's
it's especially wild because you meet so
many dedicated people who are high IQ
super trained and knowledgeable that do
all these stupid things and no they are
stupid and say I know it's stupid that's
why I don't want to do it so it's this
absurd system where we have so much
talent and intelligence that is kind of
yeah in Chains they can't like they
can't do what they should and want to do
and that's why it's so important to
break out and build companies that don't
have to adhere to these new standard
procedures but can really
strongly innovate with the patient
interest in